what's up with the TLC in general you
don't learn [ __ ] oh my god they have
other learning channel called my
80-pound groin and a man with no penis
yeah side by side on each other well the
only thing you learn from The Learning
Channel is that there's freaks in the
world
it's all reality right yeah 26:26
midgets albino midgets living in a house
on its fifth season in an island you
know and you're like what am I watching
I forgot as the Learning Channel we let
half goop with the kids what's his name
Jon and Kate Plus yeah whatever happens
on Kate Plus is different that same
thing right what's that boom chakalaka
girl what's her name
boom chakalaka the little girl that's oh
yeah yeah what that's TLC right Wow yeah
that's and that channel is killing it
right a killing in ratings
and the ratings hoarders they were Annie
at first but now yeah I mean you know I
like the one with the obsession ones oh
I like toilet paper yeah or the people
that put their hairs off that Cotulla
mania yeah yeah I have to kill Albania
in what way you do yeah I have you know
you see me I tweeze machine on your head
you don't do it no no no but I have them
say I tweeze my chin hairs every day of
my life yeah isn't that just feels
painful but so good I can't stop yeah I
mean I grew my mind is the fingers
around my I just eat the [ __ ] out of my
fingers yeah on the side and then when
you I know I meet guys that have the
same thing and then I look at them I go
oh my god were the same type of people
so my finger is sandy danto has knees
right my agent been day he doesn't even
have nails Wow I mean it's literally
just nubs now he's grinded it down so
much but it's from anxiety though esther
povitsky David King yeah he bites his
nails too it's anxiety its anxiety yes
that's one of the most like hallmark
signs of anxiety is biting your cuticles
in your nail
yeah I don't think I can ever get rid of
that it's just something that my brother
does it it's just something that we
posted but you guys do this weird thing
where you guys are obsessed with bad
smells you and your brother loved it I
hate it you're always like oh you know
what I do you know what I do what I cup
my farts I do it too dog yes I just pop
up and then I smell them you smell it
yeah I cop it to throw it to see what
it's like yeah me too I want to know
what it's like because if it's like not
smelly I go I'm healthy today but if
it's like deep and then I'm like you
never look up your own fart never cup
John farts
well one time I trapped it in like a
tick tock tick tack box and I had my
spirit a tiny hole I put it in a tic tac
box and I told my sisters like hey look
there's no candy but it still smells
minty that's a good one I want to do
that too and she took she basically ate
my fart
yeah ten years old I don't do it as an
adult
I want to do it in a maybe not by delay
a jar jug to see what happens
how can you fart in the jug like for a
year and keep keep it in there you store
the smell you just it would just have to
be vacuum sealed it and I'm vacuum
sealer I'm sorry it would just have to
be airtight interesting you know how do
you do that like because if you release
the plug to you know it had it would
have to be a one-way seal yeah so it
can't come out like a valve so it can't
come back out the other way they have to
be airtight just one direction
can somebody invent that you invent a
mechanism set it to Buffy not being real
you could trademark your scent call it
popcorn pop course you know Bobby's
popular yeah like a little butt piece I
could stick you know sits and then have
you know a jar a jug where it only
releases it once end and I can preserve
my farts this is interesting actually I
want to see what that's like
let me ask you this have you have you
every whatever you eaten on your body
oh god I've smelled a lot of things not
eaten what have you eaten in your body
oh I'm really really obsessed with
swallowing my own phlegm when I cop it
out I don't spit it out I have to
swallow the loop I do like always
awkwardly what do you mean like I don't
go inward I go outward like I pick my
nose enter the world yeah yeah I need it
to breathe that air like why yeah you
don't want it to escape or be given to
no because the thing is is that it's
literally the same thing it's the same
thing yeah so if I'm picking my nose and
I eat it don't judge me like yeah when
he's 12 yeah who does that everyone does
it but I just do it in a more
sophisticated way mmm how about scabs do
you eat scabs uh no never I don't even
pick them
I've eaten scabs have you no never what
about clipping your toenails and
smelling it I'd done that for sure I've
clipped my toenails and
oh wow yeah yeah I've done the stuff
toejam is my least favorite smell I
think that in c-diff to where smells
ever what are what are the two smells
I'm about to admit something right now
that I never thought I would ever admit
in my life in fact I might not admit it
let me think it through okay yeah I'm
not gonna admit it I can't do it my
birthday what she was a fun fact that
her birthday no gift then all right
here's what it is okay you know what I
do it I'm gonna do it so what I would do
it was I would take a razor blade not a
razor blade a shaver mm you know your
must what we call it yes disposable one
yeah you know I would shave the bottom
of my feet the skin you have admitted
this no but oh yeah this next up that's
right and then what I would do is stick
it I would take the shavings and stick
it in a bowl by the by the bathtub so it
dries out okay so then you would have
feet shavings from my green foot yeah in
a ball right and that would put glue in
it and I'd roll into a ball and see how
big the bulk again whoa that's elaborate
right Wow you basically have like he has
a drying process you do that with food
it's a meatball yeah yeah and then so
one day I went Christine was living you
have told me this story
she found a bulb that big yeah it was
4years and if you smelled it it was not
you would you would literally vomit yeah
and I've never admitted that before in
my life you have I've never seen
Christine say when you found she found
it I was just a glueball
ya know was heavy jeez yeah it was
yellow it looked like mucus but it was
solid Oh
poor girl Guinness World Record did you
ever admit that to her what it was no I
just made it now you can't say I think I
might have one I might write her and be
like hey that ball was waiting what yeah
[Music]